passengers on board an Alaska Airlines
jet were among the first to witness the
solar eclipse they saw the phenomenon
yesterday for more than 35,000 feet over
the Pacific Ocean cool right now so also
at planes flying yesterday scientists
gained a great deal of information
flying high above the earth time-lapse
video from downtown Nashville captured
the total eclipse from the ground you
can see the city disappear into darkness
David Beck knows at the city's adventure
Science Center David good morning Gail
good morning you're not going to believe
what happened here yesterday right at
the moment when the moon was about to
swallow the Sun at that exact moment the
clouds moved in and blocked ruined that
moment of totality for the people who
were here watching the only way to beat
that really would be to get above it and
that's exactly where NASA was you
already skirting above the clouds a pair
of NASA WB 57 planes flew in tandem
yesterday on a research mission to
unlock the secrets of the Sun their
precise telescopic cameras attached to
the nose of each plane captured more
than 29,000 photographs as the Sun and
Moon moved into totality to do it
NASA pilots traced the eclipses shadow
path at fifty thousand feet above
Missouri Illinois Kentucky and Tennessee
they had to be in the shadow together
for about 10 seconds for scientist at
NASA's high-altitude research program
the results felt like sweet victory they
were able to chase a solar eclipse going
450 miles an hour spaced 70 miles apart
and they hit their marks within seconds
of one another so that we could get
seven and a half minutes of totality
compared to only two minutes forty
seconds for someone standing on the
ground flying in this plane requires a
lot of specialized training we met a
mere Casspi at ellington Field in
Houston two weeks ago where NASA's
stratospheric airborne science team
hopes to learn about how energy is
transferred from inside of the Sun to
its hotter outer corona our results will
lead to a better understanding of the
corona which will eventually lead to a
better understanding
standing of flares and coronal mass
ejections which affects the public how
they can cause blackouts of
radiofrequency communications cellphones
can have trouble working it can cause
power outages by knocking out power
grids from above the earth there was
plenty of wonder too this is the moon
shadow also known as the Umbra and that
tiny speck flying across the Sun is the
International Space Station all of a
sudden this huge black shadow was going
across the earth as you might imagine
the six engineers on board the ISS had a
view that was out of this world for us
being on the witnessin from above was
just really special the hope is that
this eclipse inspired a whole new
generation to have an appreciation and
maybe even a love for science in nature
we have a treasure trove of scientific
data that nobody else has right now
our pilots and our equipment operators
hit those marks bull's eye
at the 50,000 feet mark where they were
flying the pilots told me you could
actually start to see the curvature of
the earth and bill the planet Mercury
was given the best view for those
scientists so they were labeled to look
at it yesterday and by the way not
everything worked perfectly when the
planes got up to that altitude
satellites went out they couldn't see
anything on the ground and then like
magic it all came together amazing
clouds adding drama satellites a team
drama David thanks for that